put on your two hundred and seventy
eight thousand dollar Hello Kitty pearl
necklace and say cheese for the camera
slicer
because loot is back check the time with
love a modern retro tube clock that uses
Nixie tube technology to blend vintage
and contemporary styles but if that's
not retro enough use a cuckoo clock
instead this Etsy page features handmade
modern cuckoo clocks with a retro twist
now that you know what time it is you
may have realized Valentine's Day is
quickly approaching
so grab one of these State Valentines
for your sweetheart because like they
say in Louisiana I want to be loved by
you if love isn't in the air for you
just buy some canned love air and make
sure to pick up some cans New York City
air that's 20% Empire State Building air
but may contain traces of the Bronx if
fake love from a can won't impress your
Valentine get them this fake kitten
bouquet instead that'll help you say
those awkward three words I love meow
for the dudes ditch the chocolate and
pick up some beer flavor jellybeans or
maybe this fancy barrel-aged
sriracha if you're willing to wait for a
gift there's this incredible planetarium
watch from von Cleef & Arpels or if you
need one now check out some of their
other creations like Midnight in Paris
or the poetry of time giant realistic
agates skull commemorate your love with
a custom drawing of yourselves Tod Barca
makes affordable personalized drawings
of you and your loved ones that can be
made into prints necklaces and even
candle holders and then say goodnight
and go to bed in this couple sleeping
bag but if you're in the wilderness you
might need this USB mask for allergies
to protect you from pollen start each
day like a ninja with this coffee mug
that has a black insulating ninja mask
and is armed with a deadly spoon sword
and secret throwing star coaster now
that you're energized strap these wheels
onto your shoes for instance
skates and light them up with LED
programmable light strips then relax in
the shower with some whiskey's so that
also comes in bacon and coffee flavors I
mean cents are go nuclear on dirt and
grime with nuclear soap instead and
never lose any of this loot with bringer
tabs that keep track of all your most
cherished items using the accompanying
app you can track your pets your keys or
if you forgot your phone before you
drive away you won't need one for this
all-in-one Kitchen bottle that keeps
eight essential kitchen tools in one
place but you may want to attach one to
your pirate corkscrew so you're never
without this all-purpose Buccaneer
bartender that likely has a spot on this
periodic table of swearing magnet set
that you'll use so no one messes with
your grub but maybe this table of
Thrones is more your style that includes
the codename region and house color of
each character then play ozobot a smart
robot meant to bridge the digital and
physical worlds to reinvent the classic
board game be sure to get your cat some
armor to protect you from other humans
because after all cat hair is lonely
people glitter and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you